C'est né comme une légende
la plus grande de toutes
Nous l'avons caché durant 1000 ans
Pour protéger la Terre du sort qui lui était déstiné
Optimus Prime
Tu as détruit ton monde
tu cherches la rédemption ?
Oui ma créatrice
Je la cherche
À ta fille, qu'est-ce que tu lui dirais ?
Brosse-toi les dents, fais tes devoirs,
Traine pas avec un mec qui est dans un groupe surtout le batteur,
Nous vivons des heures sombres
sans leader
Le chaos s'installe
deux mondes entrent en collision
et vous êtes notre dernier espoir
tel est désormais la plus grande des missions :
changer le sort de l'humanité
Whow
Optimus arrête, fais pas ça
La destruction de tout ce que nous connaissons et que nous aimons a commencé
Je partirai pas sans toi !
Quand tout semble perdu
quelques âmes courageuses
peuvent sauver tout ce qui nous ait cher
L'opération est terminée
On lâche pas Optimus ok ?
Je veux rester
et moi aussi je veux me battre
Pour que mon monde survive
le vôtre doit mourir